meine damen und herren mein name ist
luca und herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen video von mir sechs
bereiche eingeblendet wir machen heute
die note von baa3 sind sie oft es geht
auf jeden fall darum dass wir haben
namensschilder erstmal damit ihr wissen
ich bin ich bin look haben das ist max
fallschirm
wir haben hier zwei wochen vorbereitet
eine grüne brauchst du eine rote box das
heißt wir werden gleich abwechselnd vor
der kamera sitzen und dann werde ich
beispielsweise wenn max vor der kamera
sitzt zwei verschiedene paar ich halte
ich werde die eine box etwas schlechtes
für einen packen also das wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut schmecken wird sondern die
andere box etwas was wahrscheinlich sehr
gut in einen smoothie passen will dann
werden die box zu verschlafen und werden
getauscht und macht muss dann david haye
in welchem box entspringt ich bin doch
kein bock weil wir beim erklären nur
scheiße gebaut haben hier nochmal die
kurzfassung einer sitzt vor der kamera
und der andere der hinter der kamera ist
wird in die grüne box etwas gutes für
den smoothie reinpacken und in die rote
box etwas schlecht ist an die boxen
vertauschen und der der vor der kamera
sitzt um sich für eins entscheiden muss
hat die augen verbunden und muss sich
dann für eine box entscheiden
und das kommt dann in seinen smoothie
mit gute produkte die beispielsweise
himbeeren
kock den vier shows musa und wir haben
auf den schlecht gesagt wie
beispielsweise kakao irgendeinem
marihuana sc wir haben
honig senf dressing wir haben juli
beantragt also meine damen und herren
das ist in die beiden produkte die ich
vorbereitet habe das heißt dieses
produkt kommt hier rein und dieses
produkt kommt ihr an die beiden boxer
werden kann flossen kostet mit ihr zu
drehen
das ehepaar war das sind die zwei boxen
brauchst du nur dass du hier hinten
hallo und die box ist blau
das ist meine box leute nein bitte nicht
juli ist ist es die katze des dinge
abgeben los der ballade war dann einer
kraftraubenden hier zu mir damals eine
art perfekt
die an und sagt komm zurück du bist dran
[Musik]
also viele die gerne wer diese work klar
das ding jetzt man versucht ja als sie
von politik und welche roda was dort
steht einfach weg und die comeback
stehen dass sie meine damen und herren
polonaise nein ich würde
das hier jetzt kommt hier rein und
dieses produkt kommt
so werde ich kotzen jetzt hinstellen
freunde das heißt max du darfst kurzer
prozess die würze gut die wirklich
schlechten die gute woche
[Musik]
ich glaube das fühlt sich ein video gute
pizza und für so leute die nächsten
sachen ich platziere sind dann werdet
ihr überhaupt noch vertrauen
[Musik]
mag ich das hier vorbereitet und ich
habe das wirklich ich frag mich neben
die hier und da drin ist eine banane
[Musik]
ich mache eine rate spielt will man wäre
ja alter geil
bei mir ist mittlerweile echt eigentlich
voll okay für max habe ich das hier
vorbereitet meine damen und herren uns
dass hier das heißt die beiden sachen
kommen jetzt hin
[Musik]
ich finde drauf ist unser prozess
freunde
ich nehme die schau wird ohne familie
wolle für für gemacht erst einmal
nämlich dass hier auf der einen seite
scheiße in dem anderen wagen
das ist das eigentlich gar nicht lange
überlegen wenn man eh keine ahnung
dann kann's ähnlicher tasten also ich
nehme ich nehme das hero sa alter waren
anderen im alter oder wie gesagt wenn
ich richtig geil die ganzen sachen wenn
er nicht diese tat wurde diese wählen
wir haben auf der einen seite dieses
produkt hier und auf der anderen seite
dieses produkt schon verraten kann
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt wenn die leute wir
haben zwei boxen würde ich sagen oder in
dieser box den muss ich dann lieber nach
rechts so geht es ist ein traum oder wir
nehmen diese beiden produkte meine damen
und herren
daneben
es ist der energy drink ich weiß aber
nicht ob der schlecht oder gut ist bin
ich ganz leds okay dass letztlich die
bürgerversicherung mal schauen welche
dieser box befinden wird freunde es
tomaten sind die gut oder schlecht
findet frage ist nur dir ja schlecht ja
siehst du was
nein nein alte freunde gemacht habe mir
diese beiden dinge vorbereitet das heißt
die werde ich nochmal schön hier
reinpacken
also es sind cranberries verdammt
die alter geeignet wären ja etwas
anderen irgendwie wir uns versuchen die
begann er zu schreiben und eine kommt
dieses gemisch
ausdrucksvoll 58 nur noch zwei schlechte
sache und ein gutes was aber auch
eigentlich gar nicht so gut gebildet das
kann es aber wirklich dass es die ganze
zeit so hilft der hälfte seiner mit
guten und schlechten sachen haben ist
schon krass aufgezählt ich spüre
und warten
was stimmt hier nicht ja meine damen und
herren das ist die letzten weitere
produkte die frage ich jetzt mal eben
hier rein
das heißt das produkt für das sich max
entscheidet kommt dann machst du dir
einer das produkt das es sich nicht
entscheidet kommt mit in meinen smoothie
nebel diese box wir darin befindet sich
der physiker
ich habe ja schon und täler und monster
irgendwie arrangieren
das heißt du kriegst passiert im kopf -
nach apple muss es mal ja freunde das
sind die ganzen sachen die wir jeweils
gezogen haben
ich glaube wir haben echt hat er sicher
polonaise das dressing die götterspeise
und tomaten ich habe viel schlechte
sachen mag das weg schlechte sache
kommen wir nun zum 1 0 feed
nur wenige minuten später wurde es
riecht nach dieser frist ein zu einigen
konnte kein scheibe vors einfach
wirklich kaufen mehr vertreten
[Musik]
also als die todes lecker aus da haben
wir einfach kostet produziert wird
weil die das aus für ihn vor ja komm
jetzt auch wenn sie die ideen in einem
restaurant zu geben will ich denke ok so
gut dass man möchte dann riecht
wollt ihr mehr komplett töten ich trinke
das team durchaus nicht so krank
das kam nicht gut schmecken
er schmeckt wie ein smoothie mit
polonaise geschmack
es ist nicht so schlimm wie zu beginn
gerochen hat das ist meine mission sieht
einfach aus wie scheiße ich will für
eine echte zusammen das meint so richtig
rot braun hat einfach nur schwarz
woher kommt das nur von dem smoothie
lebt von smoothy nutella oliver kalle
es sieht auch die kakao sind einfach 1 1
aus wie kakao und ich find's nicht so
schlimm echt ganz im ernst es geht
schlimmer glaube ich aber auch echt
nicht appetitlich und also auch echte
klappt aus alter das poly reise du
trinkst das waren ab weil ist so richtig
so
da wirst du übrigens säurehaltig und
dann wird zug nach kurzer recherche
durch das deutlich wieder sofort beenden
beide damen und herren das war unsere
top box channel selection hier die
ganzen sachen die im smoothie war max
und ich habe zwei entschieden das buch
ist gedruckt nicht weiter nicht so geil
war dieses video beziehungsweise diese
challenge allerdings gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen leiter freuen und
schreibt uns und in die kommentare was
wir eventuell beim nächsten mal mit
diesen beiden boxen noch machen können
sollten da vielleicht aufgaben drin sein
fragen die dann beantworten muss oder
was komplett andere treibt viele ideen
und mutig und in die kommentare max
definitiv nicht der beschreibung
verdenken
[Musik]